HAVE NOTICED ALL OF THIS, BUT,
FOX.COM RECENTLY PUBLISHED
NAUSEATING PIECE OF A REPORTER
WHO TRAVELED TO CHINA IT TURNS
OUT ON THE GOVERNMENT'S DIME.
OVER AT "THE WASHINGTON POST"
YOU WILL PERIODICALLY SEE AND
INSERT CALLED "CHINA WATCH."
IN FACT IT'S LITERALLY A PRODUCT
OF CHINESE STATE MEDIA, THEY
PAID IT TO PLACE IT, JUST AS
THEY PUT PAID TO PLACE NUMEROUS
THINK TANKS AROUND WASHINGTON AS
WELL AS, COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IT'S A HUGE PROPAGANDA PUSH THAT
COST A LOT BUT OVER TIME, IT'S
WORTH IT.
THE CHINESE GET WHAT THEY PAY
FOR, A COMPLIANT ESTABLISHMENT
THAT USES FAKE THREATS IN
MANUFACTURED THREATS FROM RUSSIA
TO OBSCURE REAL AND IMMINENT
THREATS FROM CHINA.
IT TURNS OUT THEY REALLY ARE
TRAITORS IN WASHINGTON BUT THEY
ARE NOT WORKING FOR THE KREMLIN.
JULIAN EPSTEIN JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU AND I BOTH LIVE IN
WASHINGTON AND WE KNOW
PERSONALLY A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN EFFECT ON THE CHINESE
PAYROLL.
MADELEINE ALBRIGHT HAS MADE A
LOT OF MONEY.
SO HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU KNOW
WERE OPENLY WORKING FOR RUSSIA
IN WASHINGTON?
>> I THINK YOUR BASIC POINT, THE
CHINESE ARE A GREATER LONG-TERM
THREAT TO US THEN RUSSIA, I
THINK THAT'S TRUE.
I THINK IN THE 1970s CHINA HAD
ABOUT 1% OF THE FLOWS OF WORLD
TRADE AND THEY NOW HAVE ABOUT
25%.
ABOUT 2% OF THE GLOBAL ECONOMY
WITHIN THE DECADE, THEY WILL BE
EQUAL TO THE SIZE OF THE U.S.
ECONOMY AND BY 2050 THERE WILL
BE TWICE THE SIZE.
I THINK WHEN WE BROUGHT THEM
INTO THE WTO IN 2001 THAT IT
WOULD HELP THEM PLAY FAIR AND
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN SINCE THEN IS
THAT THEY'VE CHEATED.
THEY WERE CERTAINLY MANIPULATING
THE CURRENCY AND I DON'T THINK
THEY PLAY BY THE RULES.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS I
AGREED WITH THE PRESIDENT ON WAS
TO GET TOUGH WITH CHINA.
I THINK HE'S RIGHT TO GET TOUGH
ON CHINA AND I THINK THE MEDIA
OUGHT TO FOCUS MORE ON IT.
IT'S NOT AS SENSATIONAL SO IT'S
NOT GOING TO GET GOOD RATINGS ON
CABLE TELEVISION BUT IT'S A REAL
PROBLEM.
THE DISAPPEARING MIDDLE CLASS
AND IS A REAL PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT SENSATIONAL AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A SUGAR HIGH FOR
CABLE TELEVISION SO I DON'T
THINK YOU WILL HAVE ANY OF THE
NETWORKS, NOT THIS NETWORK, NOT
CNN, NOT MSN OR NBC FOCUSING ON
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE YOU DON'T
GET THE SUGAR HIGH FROM THAT.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY RUSSIA ISN'T A
THREAT.
RUSSIA HAS DONE LOTS OF THINGS
AND EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE 1% IN
THE WORLD ECONOMY, THEY'LL STILL
DO LOTS OF THINGS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY OPPOSITIONAL TO US AND
OUR TRYING TO DESTABILIZE US
WHETHER IT'S IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
IN SYRIA, OR THE U.K.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE NOT A
REAL THREAT AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING TO TAKE SERIOUSLY BUT
I THINK YOUR BASIC POINT IS
CORRECT.
THAT WE ARE SLEEPING WHILE ROME
BURNS WITH RESPECT TO CHINA AND
WE HAVE NOT TAKEN SERIOUSLY THE
FACT THAT THEY DON'T PLAY BY THE
RULES.
>> Tucker: I'M WAITING TO JUMP
IN WITH A HOSTILE QUESTION BUT
YOU ARE MAKING MY CASE FOR ME.
I THINK YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HONEST
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN THING, THERE
ARE A TON OF REPUBLICANS WORKING
ON BEHALF OF CHINA I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE FINALLY WAKING
UP THAT THERE IS A REAL THREAT
THAT CHINA DOESN'T PLAY BY THE
RULES.
I THINK HE'S RIGHT TO SAY THIS
IS A REAL PROBLEM.
>> THERE IS ALL THIS MORAL
OUTRAGE ABOUT RUSSIA AND
SAUDI ARABIA, NEITHER OF WHICH
I'VE EVER BEEN IN FAVOR OF BY
THE WAY.
BUT THE IDEA THAT A COUNTRY WE
ARE ALLIED WITH SS NEEDS ONE OF
ITS POLITICAL OPPONENTS, THAT'S
BAD BUT IT'S A DAILY OCCURRENCE
IN CHINA AND NO ONE SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I JUST WONDER SHOULD WE TREAT
THE PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON, WHO
HAVE A LOT OF POWER, SHOULD WE
TREAT THEM AS TRADERS IN THE
SAME WAY THAT ANYONE WHO DEALS
WITH RUSSIA IS A TRAITOR?
>> I THINK YOUR POINT ABOUT
EVENHANDEDNESS IS WELL TAKEN.
I THINK THE CHINESE DO HORRIBLE
THINGS TO JOURNALISTS AND
DISSIDENTS AND I THINK IN A LOT
OF CASES THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANTS
ENABLE THE BAD BEHAVIOR THAT'S
GOING ON IN A LOT OF AUTOCRATIC
MACHINE REGIMES.
I THINK IF YOUR POINT IS
PROPORTIONALITY, THE NEWS, AND
PARTICULARLY CABLE NEWS, I AGREE
WITH THAT POINT THAT YOU ARE
MAKING.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN TO SAY THAT
WHEN THE SAUDIS GO AND KILL AN
AMERICAN JOURNALIST THAT WE
SHOULDN'T GET TOUGH ON THE
SAUDIS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN TO SAY IF THE
RUSSIANS CREATE A MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE ATTACK ON THE
UNITED STATES THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE SHOULD TAKE
SERIOUSLY AND WE SHOULD GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT.
BUT YOUR BASIC POINT IS THERE IS
SELECTIVE OUTRAGE, LOTS OF CHEST
STEPPING AND MORALLY SUPERIOR
INDIGNATION THAT OCCURS ON THE
RUSSIA ISSUE.
AND YOU AND I MAY HAVE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT VIEWS ON THAT.
>> I'M TRYING TO ARGUE WITH YOU
BUT YOU ARE DOING A BETTER JOB
THAN I COULD.
I THINK THERE'S A REASON TO BE
UPSET ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
RUSSIA AND REASON TO BE UPSET
WITH SAUDI ARABIA BUT IF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE OUTRAGED ON THOSE